So let's see what does it
take to have a good cache?
Or what are the properties
of a good cache?
We want our system to have a good
average memory access time, or AMAT.
And this is the access time to
memory as seen by the processor.
The AMAT is equal to
the cache's hit time,
how quickly can it return the data
when we do have a cache hit,
plus how often do we have a miss,
times the miss penalty.
We want the AMAT to be very low,
the lower the better.
This means that we want the hit time to
be low, which means we want a small and
fast cache because that will
contribute to having this be low.
We want a low miss rate, which means we
want our cache to be large and/or smart.
If it's a large cache, more stuff will
fit in it, so we will miss less often.
Or if it's smart, it will know better
what to keep inside, so, again,
we will have fewer misses.
The miss penalty for simple cache is
simply the main memory access time.
This is going to be very large,
usually tens or
even hundreds of processor cycles.
So really when we are designing caches,
we're trying to balance the hit time and
the miss rate.
Small and fast versus large and
intelligent, and
intelligent typically
means slightly slower.
So some caches can be extremely small
and fast, have very good hit time,
but sometimes that's at the expense
of having a larger miss rate.
Some caches will have
a relatively large hit time but
extremely low miss rates so that we
can reduce the overall contribution
of main memory accesses that contribute
a lot each time we have them.
Sometimes we also talk about miss time,
which is the overall time it
takes to have a cache miss.
A miss time is simply the hit time
followed by the miss penalty,
because we try to find what we
have in the cache but fail, and
then we still have to
pay the miss penalty.
We can also think about miss time is the
memory access time when we are missing.
So miss rate is one.
So again, it will be the hit
time plus the miss penalty.
So another way to write the AMAT
expression would be to say that it is 1
minus miss rate times the hit time.
So this is how often do we have
the hits times the time for the hit.
Plus how often do we have
the misses times the miss time.
Usually we want to use this expression,
simply because the miss time typically
includes checking whether what
we have is in the cache followed by
whatever we need to do on a miss.
So somehow, every time it will
have the time it takes to hit but
sometimes we will also
pay the miss penalty.